in the scp system uncontained anomalies
are considered especially heinous at the
scp foundation the dedicated operatives
who investigate and neutralize these
deadly aberrations are members of elite
specialized squads known as mobile task
forces these are their stories
hey that was pretty good someone should
make a tv show about this but i digress
mtfs are a vital part of what keeps the
scp foundation up and running and keeps
the public safe from all kinds of
dangerous anomalies mtfs specialize in a
wide variety of different threats and
can be dispatched to handle those
threats when ordinary field operatives
just won't do they might be a large army
of militarized on-the-ground forces or a
tiny group of highly qualified
researchers it all depends on their
specialty and what sorts of threats the
task force exists to handle either way
they represent the best of the best that
the foundation has to offer if given the
opportunity to join one of these oh so
exclusive task forces which would you
choose and why we posed this question to
our loyal viewers here at scp explained
and received as wide and varied a number
of responses as the mtfs themselves so
without further ado let's get into it
and see who's suiting up for battle
brushing up on their thumatology or
trying to crack down on that pesky dr
bright once and for all luna hartnett
said beta 7 maz hatters the cleanup and
containment of biohazardous anomalies
sounds like grueling work mentally and
physically but it also lines up pretty
well with my real world skill set listen
one of the most important parts of job
hunting is knowing your strengths if
your strength lies with cleaning up all
kinds of supernatural gunk goo and slime
then more power to you grab a department
issued super mop and get down to it
thank you for your service a clean
foundation is an effective foundation
iron clamp said mew13 ghostbusters
everyone knows how scary fighting the
scps that you can actually see and
physically deal with are but imagine the
steel balls it takes to go into a scene
to deal with a potentially deadly scp
that you can't do either of those things
with it would be like having a much more
violent version of paranormal activity
or insidious but instead you have to
figure out how to deal with it also the
idea of ghostbusters but with guns is
just too good for me to pass sounds like
you're a horror fan so enjoy your own
personal entry into the paranormal
activity extended universe and try your
best not to become a ghost yourself we
gonna call yanuska a1 said i would
definitely want to be a member of
epsilon 11 nine-tailed fox the fact that
they're only called in to deal with a
facility and in such small teams proves
that the skill set of these troops is
astonishing not to mention they're under
the command of alpha one red right hand
who are known as the best of the best
also probing their skills in the game
scp containment breach where three
troops are sent into a facility where
some of the most famous scps have
breached such as scp-173 scp-049
scp-106 and many more they easily sweep
through the facility with no casualties
so in my opinion epsilon 11 would be my
go-to task force you've definitely got
your work cut out for you if you want to
become a member of epsilon 11 and serve
the red right hand but if you can hold
your own against the likes of the
sculpture the old man and the plague
doctor then go right ahead and try i
hope you've got quick reflexes an itchy
trigger finger and can go hours without
blinking rift z said i'd proudly wear
the insignia of mtf 8-10 see no evil i
think visual cognitohazards is a really
interesting thing to work with
interesting sure and extremely dangerous
too good job knowing what you want and
knowing that what you want is to risk
exposure to all kinds of things that'll
make it impossible to trust your own
eyes don't worry we've heard working
with eta 10 is a lot like a game of
marco polo only if you get it wrong you
break your brain die and unleash
unspeakable destruction on countless
innocent people the drum major said
definitely mtf alpha 9 last hope i've
always loved the more human friendly
anomalies and feel like even the most
hostile sentient entities have some sort
of kindness within them they can be
shown if given time being able to work
alongside these friendly entities to
help people would be amazing oh that's
so sweet so instead of just containing
anomalies you'd like to have them as
your co-workers it is a pretty
impressive team you'd be joining one
that includes the likes of iris thompson
scp-4051 also known as your friendly
neighborhood ketter and the shadowy icon
of crime fighting we call the spectre
but there's no need to be intimidated
i'm sure you have your own strengths to
bring to the table too maybe you always
get everyone's coffee order right or
you're great at giving pep talks
whatever it is you'll be a great
addition to the team lemon demon
dengaropa oh the name you have there
said it would be interesting for me to
be a part of mtf omega 9 also known as
the scrubs for context they are a group
of gamers who got trapped in a lobby of
quake and now help out the foundation
while being stuck in a game would have
some psychological consequences it would
be fun to 360 no scope the competition
and other scps who dare stand in my way
why settle for being a twitch streamer
or a professional in the world of
esports when you could just leave your
earthly life behind completely and spend
the rest of your days in a world of
pixels and non-stop action you'll miss
your friends and family sure but don't
think too hard about that part the rest
of it sounds pretty poggers do people
still say that don't tell me i don't
want to know god i'm cringe the raging
adams said this isn't even a contest i'd
go with mtf sigma 3 the bibliographers
of course not until after the whole
library invasion thing had cooled off
and they reorganized it's just the
closest you could get in the foundation
to recreational anomalous usage which is
awesome who knows maybe i'll sacrifice
everything i hold dear to become a type
blue smart move waiting for the action
to cool off first if you end up becoming
a type blue let us know i need a magic
act for my nephew's birthday party and
he said last year's amazing melvin
pulling a rabbit out of a hat wasn't
cool enough for his sixth grade friends
he's really hurtful mannequin skywalker
okay that was funny said honestly going
to say mtf lambda14 one star reviewers
i've got a lot of experience in retail
in many different positions so i think
i'd fit in there with being able to tell
what seems anomalous or potentially how
to deal with a retail oriented scp
including
a karen class after working in retail
i'm sure you've seen horrors that would
put the findings of the scp foundation
to shame after you've dealt with unruly
customers picking a fight about coupons
20 minutes after closing time there's
nothing you can't handle tor the jackal
said i'd go with zeta 9 mole rats i love
enclosed spaces especially those
underground if given the opportunity i
would definitely join zeta9 are you sure
you're not part mole groundhog maybe
i've never met anyone who quote loves
enclosed spaces let alone underground
ones but i also got kicked out of my
local spelunking team for crying too
much so maybe that's just me
sharky reynolds said i'd go for mtf
lambda 5 white rabbits and i would use
my training to determine if the terrible
new songs coming out these days are only
popular through reality warping
properties or if the world is doomed to
experience bad taste it's probably
anomalies after all everyone knows that
bad music is a brand new invention and
every previous generation didn't think
the exact same thing about the new music
their kids were listening to hang on i'm
being told that's absolutely what
happened and that taste is subjective
sounds fake besides there's got to be a
supernatural explanation for what does
the fox say i won't hear otherwise
banana1 said zeta9 mole rats i gotta
respect this task force since they have
the lowest survival rate when it comes
to their missions besides i like how
their insignia was made with the design
of a gas mask we've got another
volunteer for the mole rats what is it
with you guys and dangerous underground
situations it is a cool insignia sure
but there's a reason it's a gas mask
you'll need to wear
a gas mask good luck to you i guess
nick t wolfe discusses said for me it's
kind of a tie between two groups i would
love to be on mtf eta 11 savage beasts i
know i'm not 100 deaf and working on
learning sign language being part of a
group where i felt like i belonged and
might be accepted would be a dream come
true if i couldn't get into there mtf's
sigma 3 bibliographers would be amazing
the idea of possibly spending time doing
research and gathering info in the
library would be a great experience and
in possible downtime all of those books
that are waiting to be read that is a
great reason the savage beasts would be
lucky to have you and you deserve to
work with a team that understands and
appreciates your unique strengths maybe
you could split your time between the
two and moonlight as a bibliographer
eternal tribute said i choose tau-5
samsara i already feel basically
emotionless so it would have zero impact
on me and i like the idea of immortality
and being a cyborg i love technology
however my alternative would be the
debuggers or skynet because i am decent
with computers um hey buddy uh you okay
i'm just checking fabian robert said mtf
beta triple 7 hectates spear because i
think it'd be interesting to look for
knowledge about the occult rituals and
how to stop them especially in instances
where an scp was involved specializing
in thaumaturgical ritual analysis eh
it's the closest thing out here to
joining a literal wizard army so i can
see the appeal just be careful the world
of thumatology attracts the attention of
forces you don't want putting a magical
target on your back unlike the
aforementioned amazing melvin these guys
are doing this stuff for real and
they'll do a lot worse than sawing you
in half if you slip up on the job mr
pixel said i would probably want to be
part of mtf epsilon 9 the fire eaters
after all who can say no to the alluring
destructive power of fire and it's not a
war crime if i roast mostly anomalous
creatures instead of humans for the
second time in this video i say are you
okay buddy maybe you should have a glass
of water you can't use it to roast your
enemies alive but
it'll help you settle down
nicotine said skynet of course the
internet is a vast ocean containing both
everything and nothing thus giving me
something to do for the rest of time or
at least until the world ends plus what
better excuse than being a member of
skynet would i have to watch you guys
all day
now you're talking when you're not
tracking sentient malware or the
influence of the archon board you can
spend your time watching more videos
from scp explained that's the perfect
way to unwind after a long day of
scouring the web for old gods and i
don't know an iphone app that knows when
you're going to die you're the web
expert not me hey maybe you could teach
me how to make a tick tock that was
cringe incidentally we do have a tick
tock now at scp-explained official go
check it out after the video apple 3 3d
said beta 7. i'm a biochemist in real
life so this would just go well with my
skill sets working with anomalous
biohazard cleanup sounds like grueling
mental and physical work i didn't know
we had biochemists watching us that's
awesome you're probably overqualified to
clean up biohazardous anomalous material
but dress for the job you want by which
i mean you should probably wear a hazmat
suit and some heavy duty goggles who
knows what kind of radioactive slime and
monster snot you'll be wiping up jay the
monkey of cherry trees said if i was
asked to join any of the mtf teams most
likely after looking into them it would
be mtf theta 4 the gardeners seeing that
many mtf teams usually follow certain
protocols garner seems to be situated
around very flora-based scps usually in
sites or locations of known flora based
as cps either mitigating the effects
securing or researching potential
sprouts of scps maybe some woodworkers
skills might come in handy helping the
team though i thoroughly wonder if the
scp foundation would trust a man in an
mtf team called gardeners whom as a
bonsai plum tree growing from their head
well that's so nice you must have a hell
of a green thu hold on wait i'm sorry
what was that last part bonsai plum tree
growing from your head for the third and
hopefully final time are you okay
blink twice if you're in danger james
harold said definitely mtf gamma 13
asimov's lawbringers they're the group
in charge of dealing with anderson
robotics who's the most interesting
group outside of maybe the church of the
broken god to me anderson robotics has
been a cybernetic thorn in the
foundation side since 2007 with
influence all throughout the pacific
northwest of the united states as well
as branches in new mexico arizona and
louisiana they're an elusive group and
while they're unlikely to attack the
foundation directly their use of science
and magic in one mysterious package is
definitely something to keep an eye on
fish hissif
i see what you did there said i'd have
to go with upsilon 23 art critics i'm
usually drawing or painting so i'm down
to get my hands dirty dealing with
anomalous art and i love sloths you like
drawing and painting so naturally you
like to work with anomalous art
makes sense you might want to steer
clear of any art depicting scp-2774
though if you want to continue loving
sloths that thing will ruin sloths for
you faster than you can say nowhere is
safe in the corner of my eye it's just
staring i don't know i don't know
charles watson said mtf 8 of 5 jaeger
bombers sounds exactly like my dream job
bombing runs in something like a c130 is
already something i'm interested in and
getting to fight what are essentially
kaiju monsters makes it 10 times better
hell yeah dude i love to party oh you
said fighting
bombing runs i grossly misunderstood
what eta 5 is responsible for i'll just
put this bottle of jagermeister away and
get back to work final advance said mtf
ada 11 savage beasts i get triggered by
even non-anomalous noises easily so
dealing with audio-based cognitohazards
where noise discipline and actively
shutting out sounds is perfect for me if
you hate sounds i guess there's no
better workplace than somewhere where
you have to avoid hearing things at all
costs you'll be facing off against
trumpets that can collapse walls an
anomalous chord progression and even a
corrupted beatles song so make sure you
get some really good quality noise
cancelling headphones though or you'll
be in for a rude awakening alexander
berry said
write 99 oh no you don't as a way to
contain them more efficiently i'd have
them set up some form of comedic
entertainment to be broadcasted
throughout the foundation to boost
morale while keeping the brights
entertained of course to be safe we'll
keep an eye on all items they have
access to and run the broadcast through
a filter to get rid of possible cognito
hazards oh no you don't is right if
you're a regular viewer of this channel
or a fan of the designated page on the
scp wiki you know that there are more
things dr bright is not allowed to do
then there are things he is it'll take
some pretty good comedic entertainment
to keep wright occupied i don't think
you can just throw on spongebob or coco
melon and call it a day dr bright is way
too attracted to real life chaos to be
distracted by television though it's a
nice enough idea or wait are you
suggesting we give dr bright his own tv
show that is too much power you can not
let him on the airwaves he'll have half
the foundation quacking like a duck and
making the other half's head explode
before you even change the channel sorry
your request to join bright 99 has been
denied kurt gamer said i would proudly
put the insignia of mtf theta 90 on my
shoulder knowing that i have defended
humanity especially children from the
anomalous mathematics problems i will
even happily lay down my life to protect
children from trauma stress and
especially depression that anomalous
math can do i think math in its entirety
is even anomalous let us rally together
to ask the o5 council to contain math
entirely due to its anomalous ability to
make anyone cry and be depressed i hope
my work can bring a smile to the
children that i have defended this
brought a tear to my eye thank you kurt
for your willingness to fight against
the scourge that is simple mathematics
with your hard work children all over
the world will never need to hear about
billy buying 30 watermelons and 22
apples ever again now go check out scp
elite mobile task force explained and
scp global occult coalition explained
for more specialized groups at the scp
foundation